Speaker 1: One of the things that has been said
about Trump's 2024 campaign is that he's going
to pick a female running mate. And the names
that keep being tossed around primarily are
Nikki Haley. In no particular order, Nikki
Haley, Cory Lake, Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
and Kristi Noem. Of those, I genuinely have
no idea which is the most likely one of the
craziest is Carrie Lake. And Carrie Lake does
seem very desperate to be Donald Trump's vice
presidential running mate. And so she is wasting
no time. Remember that tonight, Ron DeSantis is
going to be announcing his candidacy against Trump
in the Republican primary. Carrie Lake getting a
jump on the character assassination. Appearing
last night on Newsmax and saying, If DeSantis
can't even beat Disney, how is he going to beat
Donald Trump? Certainly seems to be auditioning
for vice president. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: But we can't do it half assed.
When you pick a fight with Disney. You need to
play to win. And so far, Governor DeSantis has
been outworked and outmaneuvered by Disney. As far
as I know, Reading Creek is still exists. They're
still hosting trans events at their park.
Speaker 1: What is a trans event, exactly?
Speaker 2: This indoctrination is continuing
and they're actually rubbing it in the faces
of American families. You know, if you
can't beat Donald Duck, how are you going
to beat Donald Trump?
Speaker 1: Whoa,
That's pretty slick as far as a line goes.
Speaker 2: I think that's the question we have
to ask when it comes to Governor DeSantis. And
I think he should stay in Florida and continue
fighting for the people there and try to finish
that that fight. I'd rather see President Trump,
who's a dealmaker, who can make things
happen, take on woke corporations. And
I know for a fact he gets results.
Speaker 1: There you go. So Kerry
Lake coming out and saying, I wonder how how
long it took her to come up with that. If
DeSantis does sanctimonious, if the scientists
can't beat Donald Duck, how is he going to beat
Donald Trump? And she seems visibly proud of that
one. So Carrie Lake auditioning for VP. And I
actually think you're going to see an interesting
dynamic where even the people that support Trump,
many of them, they're not going to be willing to
do the character assassination of Ron DeSantis
because big picture, they actually like him. This
idea that you would love Trump but hate DeSantis,
there are sort of two sides of the same coin. So
a lot of this character assassination of one in
favor of the other is quite contrived. The reality
is that on issues and positions and culture,
war and the whole thing, to the extent that they
take positions on issues, most people who like
one of these clowns would like the other, that's
the reality. And so when you see someone like Kari
Lake draw these seemingly insurmountable, obvious,
glaring distinctions between Trump and DeSantis,
they're quite contrived and they're usually
for politically opportunistic reasons. Bonus
clip from Kari Lake. She also said during the
same appearance. Other people are crazy and not
living in reality, which is quite rich for Kari
Lake to say, who keeps insisting any day she's
going to be made governor of Arizona.
Speaker 3: The media has lost their
collective mind, have they not? Yeah.
Speaker 2: They're living on planet
crazy. And I don't frankly want to be on
that same planet with them because, well.
Speaker 1: You'd better find a flight out, Kerry,
because you've been on the planet for you're one
of the earliest settlers of that planet lost.
Speaker 2: Their minds. You know, they'll say
anything. It shows you how desperate they are.
They're just completely desperate right now. Yeah.
Speaker 1: She seems to be describing
herself and her supporters as no no ability
to analyze her, her own situation.
Speaker 3: The media has lost their
collective mind, have they not? Yeah.
Speaker 2: They're living on planet
crazy. And I don't frankly want to be
on that same planet with them because
they've lost their minds. You know, they'll
say anything. It shows you how desperate
they are. They're just.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Kerry Lake is likely to be one of the.
Is it is it impolite to say an attack dog?
Because Trump always talks about they treated him
like a dog. She is likely going to be one of the
big attackers of Ron DeSantis. This is going to
continue. And it will be very interesting to see
the aftermath tonight. In the meantime, Trump
immediately jumping to attacking Ron DeSantis.